yale university once considered our
nation's foremost home
of patriarchy and wasp culture has
apparently changed its tune in recent
years
as evidenced by a recent lecture during
which a leftist psychiatrist
described her desire to shoot white guys
this is the cost of talking to white
people the cost of your own life has
been stuffy dry
there are no good apples okay
why people make my blood boil i had the
fantasies of
loading a revolver into the head of any
wet person that got in my way
gearing their body and wiping my bloody
hands as i walked away relatively
differently
with the bouncing myself
country kill white males that's gonna be
the new
the new alma mater of yale apparently
tough out there for a white guy these
days apparently
if you think of a white guy can't walk
down the streets of new haven at yale
without being threatened with a gun
then really something has gone crazy in
this country
now anybody walks down the streets of
new haven and gets threatened with a gun
that that's sort of ordinary but
generally
our view of yale right is this is the
patriarchy this is the wasp culture
this is where the white men wield their
power
over the society and that's not really
true that i don't
if it ever was true it certainly isn't
true now now
lecturers give whole talks at yale
university
unironically about how they want to
shoot white men it's not as though
this was just an example used as a kind
of ironic joke but then she's realized
that she shouldn't do this
no she was being very earnest she thinks
that white men are deserving of
violent death at her hands and it's not
just this kind of
insane i mean it is insane she's an
insane woman but
it's not just an emotional outburst she
actually made
an argument the talk is called the
psychopathic problem of the white mind
and this psychopath who gave the talk
decided to project and accuse her
opponents of that
that uh thing from which she she suffers
this was given at the yale school of
medicine's
child study center and uh the woman's
name is dr
aruna kilani and
here is her argument the white people
are out of their minds they have been
for a long time
so remember the psychological
predicament because
when people feel that we are bullying
them when we bring up rape
they feel that we should be thanking
them for all that they have done for us
they are confused and so are we
can you hear me okay yes
okay we keep forgetting that directly
talking about race is a waste of our
breath
we are asking a demented violent
predator
who thinks that they're a state or a
superhero to accept responsibility
it ain't gonna happen they have five
holes in their brain
it's like banging your head against a
brick wall it's just like true is not a
good idea
we need to remember that directly
talking about race to white people is
useless
because we're at the wrong level of
conversation
addressing racism assumes that white
people can see and process
what we are talking about they can't
that's why they sound demented
they don't even know they have a mask on
white people think it's their actual
faith
we need to get to know them so the first
point which is obvious
within seconds of listening to this
woman is that everything that she
accuses
white people of being and doing
she herself is and does right so she
calls white people demented
this woman is clearly demented she
accuses white people of being incapable
of
rational thought she herself is not only
incapable of rational thought
at the moment at least but she denies
the possibility of rational thought
right and
and so beyond her insane babbling
there is an argument here it's an
argument that stops arguments
we often talk about the chesterton quote
there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped she is expressing
that right here
and the reason i bring it up is not just
because some insane lady said something
crazy at yale if that's all we focused
on and that would be the subject of the
show every single day
because there are plenty examples of
that the the reason i bring it up is
because this is
what we're talking about when we talk
about critical race theory
not just the obsession with sex or race
rather
not just there's also sexual politics
which we'll get to a little bit later
it's not just the obsession with race
it's not just the vilification of people
on the basis of their race namely white
people
it's more importantly the denial
of rational thought the denial of our
ability to understand things whenever
you hear
these radical leftists talking about how
you
you can't deny my lived experience and
you can never know what it is
to suffer this sort of oppression and
you can
never empathize and you know
what they're saying is you don't have
perception conception faculties of
reason you're not
capable of intellect and and furthermore
when when she says it's a waste of
breath to talk about these things to
white people
she's expressing a central tenet of
this kind of critical race theory or
critical theory or the broader
20th century sort of neo-marxist
tradition namely
that we are going to deny
objective reality and in so doing we're
going to deny
that the words which refer to objective
reality have any meaning
this is actually at the very heart of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words because
mine's available now for pre-order the
idea that because there's no such thing
as objective reality there's no such
thing as nature to which we're bound
and this actually on the sex point
relates to transgenderism because it
means we're not even bound to
our very own sexual nature but because
there's no objective thing that we're
bound to
then words can just mean whatever we
want them to it's like humpty dumpty in
alice in wonderland
in alice in wonderland humpty dumpty is
there and he says
here and in my world words can mean
whatever i want them to mean and alice
says
can words really mean so many things and
humpty dumpty responds and says
that is not the question the question is
what is to be master that is all the
question isn't what do the words i mean
the question is
who gets to define the words and if i
can define all the words
i can redefine reality that's the
premise that we're working on here
stop stop don't go you see i'm waving
the flag of the french army here to get
your attention
you've got to subscribe you got to ring
that bell you got to like you got to
make sure you get the notifications for
these videos because big tech
doesn't always want that to happen you
can also head on over to apple podcast
google play stitcher
spotify aol instant messenger all over
the place netscape
to get the audio podcast please leave a
five star review we really appreciate it
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you